[Music]
thank you ted well january is national
glaucoma awareness month as the leading
cause of blindness experts consider it
the silent thief of sight because of the
symptoms basically they can creep up on
you but there's promising new treatments
for the eye disease now think of the
optic nerve as a cable that connects
your brain to your eyes
if that signal is disrupted it can cause
vision loss
trouble is in early stages glaucoma is
very subtle most people aren't even
aware
they're losing their vision by the time
it's diagnosed
the vision loss is permanent and there's
no cure
dr jeannette lee with shepard eye center
says lowering pressure
in the eye is critical to slowing down
the vision loss
we can also do that with laser so
selective laser trabeculoplasty or slt
is a commonly performed procedure to
lower the eye pressure
and this works well for people who have
trouble putting in their drops maybe if
you have arthritis and it's really hard
for you to put in the drops
or just for you hard for you to remember
to put in drops multiple times a day
and finally we have surgical treatments
for glaucoma um surgical treatments and
glaucoma
have become a very exciting field in the
last couple of years
there are now a lot of surgeries
available to treat glaucoma that have
less complications and better recovery
the time than traditional glaucoma
surgeries
well it's estimated that more than 3
million people in the country have
glaucoma
and half of those don't even know they
have it people who are at higher risk of
getting glaucoma including are those
people with family history that are
of african hispanic or asian heritage so
even if you have no symptoms or risk
eye factors you should still get the
baseline eye exam
at 40.